Aw yeah! Welcome to Learn English with TV
Series. Are you ready to test your English
and have a ton of fun doing it? Well, we've
compiled the test with some of the best artists
of all time according to Billboard. So you are
going to get the opportunity to put to the test
your grammar, vocabulary, pronunciation
and more. But before we jump into that,
every single week we make new lessons that
help you to understand fast speaking natives
without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles. So if
that sounds like something that you want
for your English, all you have to do is
hit that subscribe button and the bell down
below so you don't miss a single new lesson.
All right! If you're ready,
then let's do this. Aw yeah!
A common expression in rock music is to wail on
a guitar. This means to play
really well and to rock out.
If you can't fathom something,
you can't understand it. Usually
something complicated or mysterious.
To pick up the pieces means to put your life
back together or to restore your life to a
more normal state after shock or disaster.
Now, are you up for a listening challenge? The
next two songs are going to give you exactly
that. Let's check it out. Listen and choose the
best option: A, B or C to fill in the blanks.
Fill in the blanks using second
conditional and the verbs in parentheses.
Now it's
time
to check your results. So keep in mind what
we did today was an informal test, it does not
replace a proper proficiency exam in which all
of your English skills would be assessed, okay?
But let's take a look at any way about where you
might be. So if you got six to seven questions
correct, then you might be around level A1. If you
got 8 to 11 questions correct, you're around A2.
If you got 12 to 14 questions correct, you're
probably around B1. If you got 15 to 18 questions
correct, then you might be at level B2. And
finally, if you got more than 18 questions
correct, congratulations, you might be at C1 or
even C2 level. So how did you do? Let us know down
in the comments below and also check out how your
fellow learners did. And next I recommend that you
see how much knowledge you have at phrasal
verbs with this next lesson. Check it out!